Je vais essayer de me livrer là
cette mission impossible qui consiste à
essayer de faire le tour du monde dans
lequel nous vivons et de
dans lequel nous allons devoir vivre
et de tous les problèmes que ça
soulève, en très exactement une heure et quart chrono
et donc comme d'habitude je n'y arriverai pas
et donc comme d'habitude je vais essayer
de faire des choix et comme d'habitude
je vais faire un très mauvais choix qui
va consister à considérer que
je m'adresse à une population de gens
qui ont des bases scientifiques
donc je vais aller aussi vite que
possible
sur toutes les notions scientifiques et
quantitatives que j'aborderai aujourd'hui.
Voilà, ça va faire un peu "gavage des oies" mais c'est probablement le moins...
le moins mauvais arbitrage,
avec les gens qui sont dans cette salle,
dont je soupçonne au surplus que une
partie connaît déjà la chanson par coeur
ou en tout cas une bonne partie
du refrain.
Donc je vais vous parler de ce que
j'appelle la contrainte carbone,
que je vais tenter d'expliciter
et je vais essayer de resituer ça dans
le cadre du fonctionnement du monde qui
nous entoure et je vais donc commencer
par vous faire un cours d'économie,
mais je vais vous faire un cours
d'économie à ma sauce
c'est à dire que au lieu de vous parler
d'économie avec les notions dont vous
entendez classiquement parler dans le
journal je vais commencer par vous
parler d'économie avec des notions
purement physique.
Au moment où les hommes et les femmes arrivent sur la planète,
on trouve alors sur cette dernière,
des stocks divers et variés :
des arbres des poissons des océans
des montagnes etc...
que je vais ranger dans deux catégories :
1) une première catégorie concerne tout
ce qui est non-renouvelable
l'échelle d'une vie humaine, par exemple les silex.
Si vous utilisez les silex, il y en a
une certaine quantité, donc ça ne pose pas
beaucoup de problèmes mais enfin dès que vous les utilisez pour faire autre chose
beaucoup de problèmes mais enfin dès que vous les utilisez pour faire autre chose.
Vous utilisez une petite partie
d'un stock qui ne se renouvelle pas.
C'est vrai pour tous les minerais
métalliques,
c'est vrai pour les hydrocarbures aux
échelles de temps dont on parle,
il faut quelques dizaines à centaines de
millions d'années pour faire des hydrocarbures,
c'est vrai pour l'océan,
il faut un certain temps
pour faire un océan on va dire quelques
centaines de millions d'années
donc si celui qu'on a ne nous plaît plus, donc on en a pas d'autres en magasin,
donc vous avez un certain nombre de
stocks non renouvelables qui sont à notre disposition.
2) et puis vous avez également des stocks
qui se renouvellent aux échelles de temps, qui nous intéressent,
comme par exemple des arbres, comme par
exemple des animaux, etc...
comme par exemple des poissons, si on pioche dedans de manière modérée,
le stock se renouvelle au fur et à mesure qu'on l'utilise
donc on a des stocks, au début de notre histoire
économique.
Arrivent les hommes, qui vont utiliser leur force de travail, ce que, dans l'économie, vous avez appris à
Arrivent les hommes, qui vont utiliser leur force de travail, ce que, dans l'économie, vous avez appris à l'école,
on appelle W(travail),
qui vont utiliser une partie de ces
stocks, qu'on appelle de l'énergie, et on
va en parler abondamment derrière,
et qui vont faire des produits
manufacturés, parfaitement "futiles" au
début : des harpons, des arcs, des
flèches etc... "essentiels" ensuite, des
machines à café
et puis des tas de trucs
complètement futiles aussi, des maisons,
des voitures, des avions etc...
donc les hommes prennent leur travail pour faire ça, alors en
fait, les hommes se rendent compte que
faire ce genre de truc c'est intéressant
et, ils vont stocker une partie de leur
production passée,
pour augmenter la production future.
Et ça, c'est un truc qui s'appelle du
K (capital).
C'est-à-dire que c'est un bien
qui sert à augmenter la production
future, et dont l'usage va s'étaler
dans le temps,
et ce n'est pas quelque chose qui se
détruit,
au fur et à mesure qu'on s'en serve.
Ça se détruit, mais à toute petite vitesse.
Les hommes trouvent que cela est bel et
bon,
et puis, en plus, ils croissent et se
multiplient, donc ils vont le fournir de
plus en plus de travail, consommer de
plus en plus d'énergie, la leur au début,
puis l'énergie extracorporelle ensuite.
Pour faire de plus en plus de trucs
"essentiels", comme les machines à café
et plus "futiles" et cetera...
Alors dès qu'il qui commence à taper
dans les stocks non renouvelables, pour
faire ça, le niveau des stocks baisse!
Alors que, comme je le disais tout à l'heure
quand il s'agit du stock de silex, ce n'est pas très grave,
quand il s'agit du stock de bauxite, ce n'est pas encore monstrueux,
par contre, il y a un certain nombre de
stocks, et, on va en parler plus tard, qui
sont des stocks dans lesquelles la
baisse est aujourd'hui tellement perceptible,
que cela handicape, à l'évidence, la
poursuite des tendances pendant encore longtemps.
Et puis, cette activité frénétique,
va, au bout d'un moment, également
commencer à faire baisser le niveau des
stocks qui se seraient renouvelés, et
si on n'avait pas pioché trop violemment dedans.
Cela vaut, par exemple, pour le stock
forestier.
Le stock forestier, en Europe, a diminué
depuis l'an 1000, la couverture forestière est passée de 80 % à 15 %,
Le stock de poissons a été divisé
par 10, dans l'Atlantique Nord.
Donc un certain nombre de ressources renouvelables,
voient leurs stocks diminuer,
parce qu'on pioche dedans, le flux
sortant est supérieur aux flux entrants.
En faisant cette activité de plus
en plus débridée,
on va également avoir un truc qui
s'appelle la pollution était en fait un
vaste fourre-tout, dans lequel on range
ce qui est sommairement tout ce qu'ils nous embête.
Donc tout ce qu'on
aime pas : c'est de la pollution :
le bruit, la congestion,
les polluants locaux, l'effet
de serre, les déchets radioactifs,
tout ce que vous voulez... Cela s'appelle la
pollution et c'est ce qui nous embête.
Alors cette pollution, en fait, a également des effets sur l'environnement,
et si vous en avez trop, c'est-à-dire que
si vous perturbez trop l'environnement,
cela va également vous entamer vos
stocks.
Je vous parlais, tout à l'heure, de
l'océan unique que nous avons,
si on le rend trop acide ou trop pollué
ou trop riche en "ceci-cela",
il devient impropre à soutenir la vie marine,
et bien, on fiche en l'air notre stock et puis
on n'en a pas un autre qu'on peut aller
chercher au magasin.
Donc vous voyez, ça, c'est l'activité
économique des hommes.
L'activité économique des hommes est
une activité dans laquelle on
transforme des ressources naturelles
pour en faire autre chose.
Il n'existe pas une activité économique, qui
consiste à faire autre chose que
transformer les ressources naturelles.
Vos habits sont des ressources
naturelles transformées. Vos lunettes sont
des ressources naturelles transformées. Un bureau est une ressource naturelle transformée.
Le bâtiment, dans lequel nous sommes, sont
des ressources naturelles transformées.
Les voitures en pagaille, sur le parking,
sont des ressources naturelles transformées.
Du reste, le parking est une
ressource naturelle transformée !
Vous êtes dans un univers, dans lequel même
votre activité à vous,
n'est pas du tout dématérialisée, j'y reviendrai plus tard, et,
vous vivez dans un univers dans lequel la totalité de notre activité économique,
cela ne consiste que à traduire, avec une
convention,
une activité physique réelle qui est de
la transformation de ressources naturelles.
Cela n'est que ça, notre activité
économique.
Dans cette histoire, qu'est ce que
les économistes ont jugé bon de compter ?
Ils ont jugé bon, de compter, le
flux annuel qui s'appelle le PIB (Produit Intérieur Brut).
Donc le PIB (Produit Intérieur Brut),
c'est la fiche de paye de l'Humanité, dans l'activité qui consiste à
transformer des ressources naturelles en
autre chose.
C'est ça le PIB.
Pour ceux d'entre vous qui se
souviennent un peu,
de leur vieilles notions macro-économiques,
le PIB c'est la rémunération
du travail et des rentes,
aux acteurs humains. Donc il n'y a
que des acteurs humains,
dans cette affaire.
Lorsque vous passez de ressources, dont
personne n'a payé
de coût de constitution ou de reconstitution,
vers des produits transformés. Quand
vous achetez un poisson,
à l'étalage de supermarché,
Ce n'est pas le poisson que vous payez !
Le poisson est apparu tout seul dans
l'océan, sans que personne ne payent rien.
Ce que vous payez c'est tout le travail humain,
qui a permis de faire le bateau, qui est
allé sur l'océan, le pêcheur qui a
conduit le bateau, le camionneur qui a
transporté le poisson,
l'usine qui a construit camion,
les gens qui ont extrait les
hydrocarbures pour permettre
de construire le bateau, le camion, et faire
avancer tout ce beau monde etc...
Ce n'est que ça que vous payez.
Et vous payez, évidemment, des rentes
aux propriétaires du moment des ressources minières,
que, pour lesquelles, absolument personne n'a fait quoi que ce soit pour les constituer.
que pour lesquelles absolument personne n'a fait quoi que ce soit pour les constituer.
Donc le PIB, c'est une
fiche de paye, en plus c'est un flux annuel.
Alors vous voyez qu'à partir du
moment,
où on matérialise juste le flux annuel,
il est évident que, plus le flux
augmente et plus les stocks baissent vite.
Et donc le PIB, dans un monde dans
lequel nous approchons des limites physiques,
a cette caractéristique
très particulière, qu'avait soulevé,
déjà, les travaux de l'équipe Meadows,
dans, ce qu'on appelle classiquement, le
rapport du club de Rome,
qui était que, tant qu'on cherche
à avoir la croissance perpétuelle du PIB,
alors plus vite on va et plus vite
on va la faillite.
Et c'est très exactement ce qu'on est
en train de constater aujourd'hui.
Avec, comme je vais essayer de vous le montrer,
l'avenir qui ne sera pas la répétition
du passé.
Comme en ce qui concerne votre propre
corps, en général,
l'avenir n'est pas la répétition du passé. Ce n'est pas en voyant ce qu'il se passe
entre 0 et 20 ans chez un être humain,
que vous extrapoleriez raisonnablement ce
qui va se passer entre 50 et 70 ans.
C'est parfaitement dommage, je suis bien
d'accord avec vous.
Voilà, donc c'est ça
qu'il faut garder en mémoire.
On a un indicateur macroéconomique
aujourd'hui et qui est totalement imparfait.
Pourquoi ce truc a été mis au point ?
Parce qu'à l'époque, on a commencé
l'économie classique,
il y a à peu près 200 ans,
les hommes étaient, comme je vais vous le
montrer, un peu plus tard,
considérablement moins nombreux
qu'aujourd'hui,
le stock était, comparé aux
hommes, immense alors si le stock est infini,
infini, en première approximation, vous
allez pas vous embêter à passer des
deltas (variations de) stocks qui sont nuls...
Donc on a considéré que ce qu'il
fallait prendre en compte
fallait prendre en compte,
c'était le goulet d'étranglement du
moment, c'est-à-dire le nombre de paires de
bras disponibles et le capital humain
disponible et on a oublié le reste.
Les ordres de grandeur ont changé d'un
facteur 10 d'un facteur 100, d'un facteur 1000...
et on a gardé la même
approximation du premier ordre !
Si vous faisiez ça dans votre
laboratoire, vous vous feriez vertement vilipender !
Et là, les économistes font la même
chose dans leur formule,
et personne ne trouve rien à redire...
Enfin si, un certain nombre de gens comme
moi, mais en gros,
on continue à utiliser cet
indicateur, qui est grossièrement faux,
et qui ne mesure absolument pas l'état de l'humanité.
Ce qu'il aurait fallu faire,
dans cette histoire, c'est de compter en
positif, le capital manufacturier ou le stock artificiel créé,
compter également en positif, les acquis
sociaux créés, à cette occasion :
donc le capital social, le capital
culturel, etc...
Tout ce qu'on crée, à cette occasion, vous le mettez en positif,
sauf qu'il ne faut pas oublier de compter en négatifs tout ce qu'on a consommé pour ça.
Et le jour où la valeur marginale de la
dernière voiture construite,
est inférieur à la valeur marginale du
dernier morceau de stock qu'on a
utilisé pour construire la voiture et
faire avancer la voiture :
fin de la construction des voitures.
Et on vit "Happily ever after" (heureux comme dans un conte de fée) avec le nombre de voitures existantes.
C'est ça qu'il aurait fallu faire,
dans un monde, dans lequel, on aurait
correctement compté
l'état patrimonial de l'humanité et de
la planète sur laquelle elle vit.
Donc le truc qu'on est en train de faire
là, de compter juste le PIB,
c'est juste un machin qui va nous permettre
de faire faillite plus vite.
Je vais vous prendre un exemple qui va
vous parler, imaginons que j'ai hérité
- ce qui n'est pas le cas évidemment -
d'une considérable fortune de mes
parents et que je décide d'aller jouer au
casino
d'une considérable fortune de mes
parents et que je décide d'aller jouer au
casino.
Eh bien, le PIB mesure ce que je dépense au casino tous les ans.
Donc vous comprenez assez facilement que
plus mon PIB croît, et plus vite je vais à ma ruine.
Alors vous le comprenez, c'est exactement pareil,
pour ce qu'on est en train de faire, au
niveau macro. Exactement pareil.
Je vous ai parlé, tout à
l'heure, du Club de Rome (groupe de réflexion),
probablement qu'un certain nombre de
gens... Qui a entendu parler du Club
de Rome dans cette salle ?
Vous n'êtes pas représentatifs car surreprésentés... (Rires.)
J'ai posé la question à mes étudiants
des Mines, y a trois semaines,
et il y a 2 mains qui se sont levés sur 60.
Donc voilà, cela marque une époque.
Alors qu'on ils dit dans le Club de Rome ?
Ils avaient essayé de faire une modélisation dynamique du comportement de l'humanité.
Avec un certain nombre de variables
"grossières", qui étaient censées
représenter ce qui se passait.
Donc la variable "grossière", c'était, par exemple la population,
les ressources naturelles, dans lesquels
ils avaient agrégé le minerai de mercure,
les hydrocarbures, etc... donc on peut dire
que c'est un tout petit peu simpliste,
Donc vous allez voir que si on prend juste à contrainte carbone, ça marche assez bien.
Donc les ressources naturelles, la
population, la nourriture disponible, la production industrielle disponibles et les
niveaux de pollution.
Donc les ressources naturelles, la
population, la nourriture disponible, la production industrielle disponibles et les
niveaux de pollution.
On part de 1900,
et, ma foi, de 1900 jusqu'à la date
à laquelle ce rapport a été écrit (1972),
Il ne fallait pas être grand clerc pour
constater que toutes avaient crû,
d'autant la population, que la production
industrielle, que la nourriture, etc...
On a entamé, c'est à peine perceptible, les
ressources naturelles,
et on a monté, c'est à peine
perceptible, le niveau de pollution.
Est-ce que ces braves gens ont dit en
1972, date du rapport, que le monde allait s'écrouler en 2000?
Eh bien, jugez en par vous-même, voilà ce qu'il avait dit.
Voilà la
trajectoire
Voilà la trajectoire qu'ils voyaient pour le monde en scénario "business as usual".
Dans le scénario "business as usual" (business "comme d'habitude"), ils voyaient la population augmenter,
la nourriture augmenter, la production
industrielle augmenter plus vite que la population
ce qui signifie que la production par tête augmente,
le pouvoir d'achat augmente, voilà ce qui arriverait.
et les ressources, elles ont un peu baissé
mais c'est pas encore dramatique
et la pollution à monté, mais c'est pas
encore dramatique.
Donc non, l'épisode "rigolo" est pour plus tard.
Ce qu'avait dit, en fait, cette brave équipe, c'est que :
quelquesoit l'optimisme qu'on prenne
sur les conditions initiales du système,
et le niveau de ressources etc..., le
niveau de recyclage, etc...
la croissance perpétuelle est un truc
qui s'effondre dans le courant du 21e siècle.
Voilà, c'est ça qu'il avait dit ces braves gens.
C'est à dire que la croissance
perpétuelle du PIB est un truc qui ne sera pas perpétuelle du tout,
et que ça s'arrête avant que vous soyez morts pour une bonne partie des gens cette salle.
Est-ce qu'ils ont tort ? Est-ce qu'ils ont
raison ? Ça va être tout l'enjeu de notre discussion.
Alors je vous ai dit, tout à l'heure, qu'il y avais quelque chose qui jouait un rôle absolument centrale dans l'économie, c'est l'énergie.
Puisque l'économie ne consiste qu'à
transformer des ressources naturelles en autre chose.
Ça tombe bien l'énergie intervient
dès qu'on transforme quelque chose en quelque chose d'autre :
vous modifiez une température,
vous modifiez une vitesse,
vous modifiez une forme,
vous modifiez composition chimique,
vous déplacez à un corps dans un
champs potentiels avec lesquel il interagit,
vous modifiez une composition atomique, et c'est évidemment ce qui est plus intéressant pour moi elle vous fait interagir accord avec du
et, ce qui est plus intéressant pour moi, elle vous fait interagir un corps avec du rayonnement.
Là dedans, à chaque fois, vous avez de l'énergie qui est intervenue.
Et, en fait, c'est juste rappeler que, l'énergie est, par définition, l'unité de compte de la transformation du monde qui nous entoure.
Il n'y a pas de transformation qui
puisse prendre place sans que de l'énergie interviennent dans cette affaire.
Donc, dire que les gens consomment de
plus en plus d'énergie,
cela n'est rien d'autre que de dire que
chaque individu pris isolément à une aptitude à transformer son environnement qui va croissant.
C'est exactement la même chose.
Alors vous comprenez qu'il n'existe pas d'énergie "propre" ou "sale" dans l'absolu, puisque c'est juste une affaire de doses.
Si, grâce à la fusion, on mettait au point l'énergie propre, soi-disant infinie et gratuite,
et bien, j'aurais la possibilité de
ratisser la totalité des poissons de l'océan à ce coup de filet, et j'aurai la possibilité d'arracher une montagne,
ratisser la totalité des poissons de l'océan à ce coup de filet, et j'aurai la possibilité d'arraser une montagne,
en un seul clic sur un bouton et
cetera...
Est-ce que c'est un monde dans lequel on
a envie de vivre ?
On peut se poser la question...
Comme l'énergie est révélée à
l'occasion d'une transformation,
chaque transformation a ses avantages et ses inconvénients.
Mais il n'existe pas de transformation neutre car, par définition, c'est une transformation.
Donc la transformation a ses avantages
et ses inconvénients, et chaque source d'énergie présente ses avantages et
ses inconvénients.
Donc la transformation a ses avantages
et ses inconvénients, et chaque source d'énergie présente ses avantages et
ses inconvénients.
En ce qui concerne un certain nombre
de sources on a des contraintes qui sont exogènes c'est à dire qu'on ne peut
trépinier par terre et crier pouvoir d'achat et cetera...
En ce qui concerne un certain nombre
de sources on a des contraintes qui sont exogènes c'est à dire qu'on ne peut
trépinier par terre et crier pouvoir d'achat et cetera...
En ce qui concerne un certain nombre
de sources on a des contraintes qui sont exogènes c'est à dire qu'on ne peut
trépinier par terre et crier pouvoir d'achat et cetera...
En ce qui concerne un certain nombre
de sources on a des contraintes qui sont exogènes c'est à dire qu'on ne peut
trépinier par terre et crier pouvoir d'achat et cetera...
On a des contraintes exogènes et il va falloir qu'on fasse avec,
et disserter sur l'avenir énergétique, c'est faire de l'optimisation sous contrainte,
c'est-à-dire voir quels sont les degrés de liberté qui reste accessible et ceux qui deviennent interdits.
c'est-à-dire voir quels sont les degrés de liberté qui reste accessible et ceux qui deviennent interdits,
dans le monde que nous allons connaître
à l'avenir.
et, bien évidemment, vous allez voir que dans cette histoire, il n'est question que de chiffres,
et donc je vais vous assommer avec des chiffres.
Alors le premier chiffre avec lequel je
vais vous assommer, c'est celui-là.
recette aura pour la batterie de
chiffres
ce graphique représente l'évolution de
la consommation d'énergie par personne
à la surface de la planète donc c'est
une moyenne mondiale
depuis 1880 alors là dedans vous n'avez
pas le droit
c'est la seule énergie qui soient pas
représentés là-dessus et puis bon on
va dire ajouterait à peu près ça
et c'est à peu près constant depuis
depuis cette époque
alors le premier constat vous pouvez
faire c'est que depuis un siècle
la consommation de charbon par individu
pour cent en moyenne planétaire est
constante
donc le charbon n'a absolument pas
disparu
de nos cousins râble vie
en e école
si l'une des raisons à cela
c'est que le charbon représente apple
prépare pour ça on de la production
d'électricité mondiale
le charbon oui avant tout une énergie
des pays riches
les plus gros consommateurs de charbon
par tête de pipe sait les américains
les australiens c'est pas du tout les
chinois
le charbon c'est 50% d'électricité
américaine c'est 50% de l'électricité
allemande c'est 30% des lectrices
n'empêche que ça me
ces médecins quant aux six
d'électricité danoise
c'est un tiers de l'électricité
européenne a peu à peu à redire
c'est un truc et ap seulement central
dans le système électrique des pays
développés absolument central
le pétrole est venue se rajouter
là-dessus le gaz est venue se rajouter
là-dessus et cetera vous voyez que par
l'échelle
des temps d'historique
il n'existe pas qu'une forme d'énergie
qu'on est cannibalisée une autre ou
alors pas suffisamment pour sa voix sur
ce graphique
en gros c'est plutôt une superposition
décroissance
à laquelle on a eu droit
vous voyez les gaels banques les trente
glorieuses or que pour chacun de nos
dirigeants aimeraient bien reproduire sa
féminité l'ue
pour ce second était marqué par une
très forte hausse de la croissance
d'énergie par personne
et pour cent et vous m'avez déjà
compris pasteur 6
on va faire venir un certain nombre de
fois la question est bien évidemment de
savoir si on peut avoir une croissance
économique forte sans avoir de
croissance énergétique forte
et quand même
ça il meuble nucléaire sa part dans
des stocks fini
la probabilité pour que l'on ait une
croissance perpétuelle de
l'approvisionnement de ce truc-là par
personne avec une démographie qu'une
humanité dans la population est stable
et rigoureusement du
donc ça ça pose la question
de savoir-faire
comment tout ça va se comporter le camp
à l'avenir
alors vous voyez que actuellement on a
à peu près 20000 kilowattheures par
personne et par an en moyenne
planétaire
si vous vous serviez de vos bras et de
vos jambes pour avoir la même chose
quand exactement si vous aviez des
esclaves qui se servaient de leurs
droits et de leurs jambes pour avoir la
même chose il faudrait que chacun
d'entre vous
en mai alors qu'en france au contraire
aux alentours de 300
or la revue êtes plutôt aux alentours
de 100
or en france on n'est pas cinquante
mille kilowattheures par personne et par
an or ce qui est contenu dans les
importations
donc vous vous voyez que on a acquis à
travers la consommation d'énergie une
puissance de feu sans mauvais jeu de
mots absolument considérable sans
précédent dans l'histoire de
l'humanité
or la paix tous les gens qui se mettent
en grève en disant qu'ils ont dans le
passé
ne se rendent pas compte
se rendent pas compte
que ils ont déjà en france
l'équivalent de 100 imsand 50
domestique à leur disposition 24 heures
sur 24 et 365 jours par an
à travers leur consommation d'énergie
et si les raisons de la satisfaction
sont allés chercher ailleurs je vous
renvoie à deauville
qui avait expliqué qu'en démocratie on
serait perpétuellement frappe
enchaînée
% à mon avis et % et la raison est
beaucoup plus liée à serra plutôt
qu'au niveau de consommation dans
l'absolu
il faut ajouter à cela un peu dans de
consommateurs archos montée un poêle
% et vous avez ici l'évolution de la
démographie sur notre planète depuis
que l'homme se sédentariser donc
décidé de l'agriculture
au moment alors vous me pardonnerez ce
parisianisme de mauvais aloi % au moment
où l'humanité se sédentarisent on a
la moitié de la population francilienne
qui p répartie sur la terre entière
donc la population planétaire c'est la
moitié de la population francilienne
actuel
au moment où la révolution
industrielle ou agricole sa il ne
s'était pas extrêmement précis à
stepanek la
démarre
on est à peu près pas de milliards que
vous voyez quand lui génération
en huit générations
on a multiplié sa part 10
hélas on a eu une évolution qui est
plus près de l'hyperbole de lesponne en
ciel à cette année extrêmement vite
extrêmement vite
et c'est un cas extrêmement vite au
moment où on a commencé à utiliser
l'énergie abondante ce qui fait qu'un
certain nombre de gens aujourd'hui se
pose la question de savoir si une
énergie beaucoup plus contingenté
permettra de continuer à avoir quelques
milliards d'âmes sur terre
dans un sens que tout ça ne dégénère
en sondant pugilat
p c'est une vraie question
si je reviens à ma définition de
l'énergie qui est sous la pression de
l'homme sur l'environnement voilà
comment au premier rang aura évolué la
pression de prestations l'environnement
elle évolue comme la démographie
elle évolue comme la quantité
d'énergie consommée par personne
donc je compose les deux pour avoir
quelque chose qui ressemble plus au
poids l'évolution de la pression de
l'espèce sur l'environnement
et vous voyez là de manière évidente
que
les débats qu'on peut avoir aujourd'hui
ne sont pas des débats qui sont liées
aux fêtes qui on a des processus qui
ont qualitativement changé
ce sont des débats qui sont liées au
fait que là les ordres de grandeur en
jeu
outre considérablement changé c'est
juste un point dans de grandeur cette
affaire
alors nos destins virtuel aujourd'hui ou
ce qu'ils sont
des biens les voici % et vous avez tous
entre 20 et 40 paires de bras qui
turbinent en permanence pour vous dans
l'agriculture c'est ce qui a permis de
passer la population active de 70% de
paysans à 2% % et la productivité d'un
paysan pour ceux qui ont été
multipliés par 2 100 % au passage
ça tout ça c'est grâce à l'énergie
alors donc aujourd'hui parce que si vous
aviez besoin de faire pousser des
patates huit heures par jour ça serait
un peu difficile de faire dans chaque
côté
ensuite nous avons tous entre 30 et 60
esclaves à notre disposition en
permanence qui s'appelle de transport
% j'ai vu qu'il y avait un serpent de
voitures garées sur le parking ici
eh bien pour cent la puissance
développée par un moteur de voiture
s'est pas autant de chevaux attelés et
que vous avez de chevaux sur la
documentation commerciale de vote
voiture donc si vous avez une c1 et c2
à 50 chevaux
eh bien à vous dans le moteur remplacer
sa part 50 chevaux devant la carrosserie
et seule puissance développée c'est
juste pas le même prix
aujourd'hui
pour 15% de budget c'est-à-dire une
somme ridicule dans faible
vous avez les moyens de rouler dans un
carrosse avec 50 à 100 chevaux attelés
devant c'est à dire un truc absolument
personne je dis bien absolument personne
pospisil dossier
3 une personne sur terre va vers un
carrosse avec 50 chevaux devant
et aujourd'hui c'est à la portée de
600 800 millions d'individus
vous avez et nous avons tous quelques
dizaines d esclaves mécanique et
turbines en permanence dans les usines
pour nos effectifs on retrouvait tenant
les chaises sur lesquelles vous êtes
assis et que l'ordinateur dans ses
enfants de servir la tap sur lequel il
est posé les gobelets en plastique qui
étaient à l'entrée d'un site qui a
fait et cetera et cetera
c'est quelques dizaines en gros entre 50
et 100 ça dépend de la manière de
conter
dsk qui turbinent en permanence
l'énergie fossile à il est semblable
mans jouer un rôle significatif dans la
disparition des stages sur terre
c'est assez vraisemblable
et pour cent évidemment sans faire de
pronostic ça pose la question de savoir
ce qui va se passer quand il a commencé
à avoir de la contagion sur cette
énergie
ça c'est ce qui a remplacé les vaches
ça s'appelle chauffage central
après vous avez quelques dizaines
d'ateliers esclaves à votre disposition
à travers les usages spécifiques de
l'électricité c'est-à-dire tout ce
qui sert à monter et descendre des
charges
tout ce qui sert à pomper quelque chose
tout ce qui est de 7 et rate ça vous
garde les aliments au froid ça voulait
dire éventuellement si vous avez un
micron d'assabou lave-linge s'avoue la
vaisselle etc tout ça c'est des
domestiques
il y est à la consommation d'énergie
et nous en avons tous quelques dizaines
à la disposition dans la danse à 1 424
donc aujourd'hui alors que compensent et
vivra comme des miséreux avec une perte
de pouvoir d'achat et cetera nouvion
comme des nababs
un français enfin égard battue cela
c'est-à-dire qu'un français avait bien
deux siècles
qui arriverait dans le monde dans lequel
nous vivons
équipe gouvernementale et parce qu'on
en a pas assez
se demanderaient sur quelle planète il
est arrivé
parce que ya deux siècles et gens
vivaient dans une pièce ces deux-là
toute la population était paysannat
pour l'essentiel
donc les gens vivaient dans une pièce
walchhofer sans éducation pour les
gosses
sans vacances
les gens vous allez voir un peu plus
tard faisait en moyenne 2 km à pied par
jour c'était ça leur déplacement
or il avait le plan prévoit en action
toute leur vie durant sept heures je
n'ai raté que km et pas plus
khelil avait pas la musique il n'y avait
qu'à voir c'est cci il faut se rendre
compte
là où on en est arrivé aujourd'hui
alors l'une des raisons pour laquelle la
serbie à l'économie que ça puisse
passer cette affaire
c'est que contrairement à une idée
couramment répandue l'énergie et d'une
manière générale nous importe quels
biens manufacturés ne vaut pas de plus
en plus cher mais de moins en moins cher
en privé elle
donc n'importe quoi pour d'absolument
n'importe quoi
et je vais vous montrer quelques
exemples
ici et que vous avez quelque chose qui
va me permettre de démarrer mon
raisonnement qui est le prix déflatés
du pétrole depuis qu'on a commencé
l'exploitation industrielle du pétrole
alors vous voyez que le début ça fait
quelques zigzags
et puis en dix-huit 180 environ -
or le prix se stabiliser aux alentours
de 20 dollars le baril après même un
peu plus bas pendant près d'un siècle
c'est-à-dire que pendant un siècle on
a fait nos villes fait nos
infrastructures fait nos métiers effet
nos industries fait la restructuration
à l'école etc
le pétrole reste à un prix constants
pendant que le pouvoir d'achat par
personne en données réelles augmente
comme ça
sarah cp marché
les marchés
anandan le prix à la production est
beaucoup moins dans les deux sens
pour ce dont vous êtes vous avez %
le prix qui restent à peu près
constant pendant que le pouvoir d'achat
en dollars constants également du
consommateur lui il augmente d'un
facteur qu'on va dire à peu près 20
depuis 1860 et si vous prenez pour
l'évolution sociaux et dans une île
cette représentativité des occidentaux
si vous prenez l'évolution depuis le
début du siècle on est en droit
facteur 10
ça veut dire quoi cette histoire
ça veut dire que le temps qu'il faut
travailler pour se payer un kilowatt
heure de n'importe quoi a été étendue
aux divisions et par dix en l'espace
d'un siècle
et comme mardan le même laps de temps
les gens de la corporation on fait un
boulot efficace c'est-à-dire que
l'efficacité énergétique
en e1 a été multiplié par un gros par
un facteur 2 à 3
ça veut dire que le prix réel
demandais ce qui allait bien j'étais
dont je parlais tout à l'heure a été
divisé par 30 sur le courant du 20e
siècle
n'allez pas chercher ailleurs
l'augmentation du pouvoir d'achat vous
l'avez
n'allez pas chercher ailleurs
on a acquis la possibilité
de remuer trente fois plus de matière
en un siècle
que ce qu'on faisait
le mans en 19 cents
donc logement plus grand logement moins
cher voiture plus grosse voiture plus
accessible et cetera et cetera et vous
prenez absolument n'importe quel produit
manufacturé
son prix réel s'est cassé la gueule
son prix réel c'est casser la gueule
sur le courant du dernier siècle
l'avocate
alors quelques illustrations
ici vous avez la dépense énergétique
par passager-kilomètre pour faire selon
ma de transport pendant donc c'est la
quantité d'énergie qu'il faut
consommer cd grammes équivalent
pétrole suis désolé c'est pas dans le
système international
jobs pour faire ap km selon le mode de
transport
eh bien vous constatez que le sens de
l'histoire c'est d'aller vers la droite
c'est à dire que la réclamait du prix
réel de l'énergie se sont
démocratisés au fil du temps
d'abord la bicyclette puis le train
puis l'autobus puis la voiture et
l'avion
à ses essais et ses usages là ce sont
des accords à chaque fois que vous
faites un saut
dans la liste que je viens de vous
énumérer eh bien vous augmentez la
quantité d'énergie qu'il faut utiliser
pour qu'un passager parcours 1 km
il est assez vraisemblable que dans un
monde contraint sur l'énergie en fait
une partie du chemin inverse
autres manifestations liées à la
baisse du prix réel de l'énergie
l'augmentation du parc de voitures que
vous avez ici on voyait entre l'année
de ma naissance en gros et pour
aujourd'hui
eh bien le parc de voitures a été
multiplié par un facteur 4
parc mondial en
a été multiplié par un facteur 4
donc c'est pas 5% ses détracteurs 4
ici vous avez quelque chose que moi je
trouve assez intéressant même si c'est
un peu difficile à dire
c'est un échelle logarithmique 1
c'est le nombre de kilomètres fête en
moyenne par personne et par jour selon
le mode de transport en france depuis 18
cents
alors le truc qui est la référence et
la marche que vous avez en blanc
revoyant 18 cents une personne fait en
moyenne à tous modes confondus ça
c'est le violet
trois kilomètres par personne et par
jour et en fête ses cent seulement de
la marche à pied
il faut descendre trois ans de grandeur
en dessous pour trouver le cheval
qui est réservé à une micro élite
qui est capable de se déplacer en
carriole
tôt le trajet moyen
domicile-travail
du paysan de l'époque à l'époque tout
le monde était paysan vous allez voir
pas leurs 70 % des gens et des paysans
et puis les les la moitié des gens
restants étaient en plus de maisons
tout est pareil lors de trajets
domicile-travail d'après l'oms
des biens 3 km par personne et par jour
à pied
c'était ça le déplacement moyen des
gens
il faut attendre ici la reprise 952
pour que le déplacement moyen par
personne et par jour en voiture des
passes de manière significative la
quantité de kilomètres fait par
personne et par jour en
mais un certain nombre dans cette salle
qui à mon avis était déjà vivant en
donc il était déjà évident à
l'époque
houle la voiture
à supplanter la marche à pied comme
mode de transports permettant de faire
le plus de kilomètres en moyenne par
personne et par jour
c'est très très récent très très
récent
les plus jeunes dans cette salle sont
nés dans un monde dans lequel on fait
ça comme on respire c'est très récent
et vous allez voir après que la
probabilité que ça dure très
longtemps c'est une vraie question
% ici voici encore une autre
illustration de l'énergie abondante et
à bas prix et dont vous bénéficiez
dans ses locaux excentré il est
accessible uniquement en voiture
c la quantité d'énergie ces les
émissions de gaz à effet de serre qui
sont liées au confort thermique et aux
déplacements quotidiens
pour un appartement mais je peux
traduire ça pour des locaux d'activité
s'est sacrément par ailleurs
pour un appartement
comment fonction de sa localisation dans
l'ile-de-france mais ça marche quelque
soit la ville comprend
eh bien vous voyez que plus vous allez
de verre de la banlieue lointaine
et plus les émissions liées au
chauffage est liée au dés à la
mobilité quotidienne sont importantes
pour le chauffage c'est normal vous avez
plus en plus d'habitants individuel donc
une prime d'aidé la surface en contact
avec l'extérieur qui en proportion
augmente
et pour ce qui concerne les
déplacements quotidiens vous êtes dans
des tissus de plus en plus la rage
donc si vous voulez conserver la
fonction des chances que la fonction
urbaine
après donc les gens se déplacent
eh bien or vous avez de plus en plus
d'énergie qui est nécessaire pour
assurer cette fonction des changes
et c'est pas hasard si les villes
américaines qui se sont constitué un
moment où l'énergie était déjà
abondante et à bas prix
ce sont faites avec ce genre de tissus
en vain et non pas à ce genre de tissus
en main c'est parce que comme l'énergie
le ballet déjà pas grand-chose
on a fait un truc qui était adaptée à
une énergie peu chères
alors évidemment
quand l'énergie va devenir cher
% s'impose la question de savoir ce que
deviennent les charges de fonctionnement
de ce truc là
et ça pose une question qui à mon avis
est encore plus emmerdant le fait de
savoir comment vont évoluer les bassins
d'emploi
parce que ma théorie sais que ça va se
contracter
donc les gens qui sont en deuxième
couronne non seulement ils ont des
charges plus élevées mais ils ont
moins de gens
et du coup comme les engagements de
doute les banques qui leur ont fait des
crédits immobiliers ils vont pas très
bien
e ici or vous avez
toute autre chose dans la soirée par un
débat en ce moment mais je reviendrai
au moment de discussion probablement est
à mon avis assez représentatif
de ce qui nous attend mais pendant sa
petite échelle
dans un monde dans lequel on ne prend
pas ce genre de contraintes à
bras-le-corps
en e s posions du prix l'énergie
récession économique
et comme le métier des banques se prend
des paris sur l'avenir le pari ne se
matérialise pas et dans ce cas sa
gueule
si on pense que les banques sont la
cause du problème actuel on se trompe
la cause du problème actuel c'est
l'augmentation de l'endettement
c'est à dire si leur comportement
passé
mais le site là-haut l'augmentation
très forte prime énergie combien de
conduire
alors je reviens à vie et vous aurez un
petit graphique après pour l'équipe
donc je reviens à cette affaire-là
or ici vous avez tort quelque chose qui
bat en brèche une autre idée
couramment reçu
quillet que plus vous augmentez la part
des services dans l'emploi et plus votre
société et dématérialisés
et bien comme aurait dit un certain
terre sonagess célèbre de queneau bon
on etc
alors pas du tout
ici vous voyez que quand on augmente la
part des services dans l'emploi on a
tendance plutôt à augmenter les
émissions de ces eaux de bar personnes
et pour tout cas même si cette
corrélation n'est pas parfaite et une
chose de sûre c'est vous avez pas
celle-là
ben c'est pareil avec l'énergie leur
avait cessé au delà je monte
l'énergie et joueront de l'énergie sur
un ensemble de pays beaucoup plus basse
que vous avez à peu près tous les pays
du monde ici
vous voyez que si on essaye de faire une
corrélation est à la hausse et en tout
cas une chose est sûr c'est qu'elle est
pas la baisse
seulement certains nous avaient pas une
corrélation comme ça
dans ce nuage de points
donc l'idée qu'il suffit d'augmenter la
part de l'emploi dans les services pour
avoir pour régler le problème de ces
eaux de l'énergie malheureusement c'est
complètement faux
toutes choses égales par ailleurs
alors la raison à cela à mon avis elle
est tout bêtement liés ap ce graphique
ici vous avez l'évolution depuis deux
siècles de la part de l'emploi dans
chaque secteur agriculture industrie et
services
la part des agriculteurs s'étaient
dotées hareng 18 cents c'est ce que je
me disais tout à l'heure le français
ordinaire en 1804 paysans et le
français des services ordinaires donc
le tertiaire à l'époque c'était pour
une personne sur deux en plus de maisons
1 cd sort la moitié des desserts
qu'est-ce qui s'est passé
l'énergie abondante et à bas prix a
permis de remplacer pour s'en aller
paysans pour en faire des ouvriers
puis a permis de remplacer les ouvriers
pour en faire des cols blancs
esquerdes
cette affaire-là
vous laisse penser une seule seconde que
la tertiarisation est un truc qui est
indépendant de l'utilisation d'énergie
non
on a juste remplacé les fonctions
productives par des machines qui
consomment de l'énergie
pour tout le monde qu'on fond
un ratio
sur juste un truc qu'on mesure qui est
la part de l'emploi dans les services
avec la pression globale de l'homme sur
son environnement qui a
considérablement augmenté et quel que
soit l'indicateur que vous preniez
depuis cette époque
tout simplement parce que les machines
sont pas d'emploi
ainsi on peut être une machine qui
fonctionne dans la population active
or on n'aurait pas intérêt
toi tu vois je fasse quelque chose à
ses rivaux
à l'école par ailleurs un autre et
qu'on n'oublie souvent sécu rembourse
en page c'est pas une valeur absolue
alors je voulais monter tout à l'heure
pour le charbon
1 c'est pas parce que là pour le
pourcentage du charbon baisse qui ont
valeur absolue la part du charbon afin
de la quantité de charbon consommer
dacia logan
et c'est exactement pareil ici
c'est pas parce que en pourcentage les
emplois industriels ont baissé sur les
dizaines d'années qui viennent de
s'écouler que en valeur absolue en a
moins d'emplois industriels aujourd'hui
que l époque ancienne
là on avait deux millions d'emplois
industriels la roma 6 millions
pourtant la part dans l'emploi est à
peu près la même
donc en valeur absolue et si vous
regardez un indicateur qui pourrait par
exemple nombre d'ouvriers par hectares
de sols en france
et bien cet indicateur a triplé et il
n'est pas du tout descendu donc le choix
de l'indicateur était évidemment
déterminant dans la confusion
l'énergie abondante et à bas prix a
aussi permis de faire ça
pour cela vous êtes avant-guerre après
vous avez encore à peu près un tiers
de la population active qui est paysanne
ici vous êtes heureux aujourd'hui vous
avez 2% de la population active qui est
paysanne évidemment
parra à due concurrence a pas d'emploi
qui servait les paysans sont partis les
campagnes également
vous voyez que l'énergie abondante et
à bas prix à structure et à
l'urbanisme bien particulier en vie dans
les campagnes et en faisant des grandes
mégapoles est allé
ça c'est viable parce que vous pouvez
avoir de très grands bassins d'emploi
compte l'énergie vaut cher les gens
préfèrent de grandes distances en
voiture c'est pas un problème
et vous pouvez mettre beaucoup de gens
dans les activités tertiaires dans les
villes pour gérer une production faite
par des machines parce que c'est ça les
activités tertiaires ainsi gérer une
production faite par des machines
e il comprit vaud
les moyens d'observation d'utiliser ces
machines
donc heures on peut gérer ddd machina
en mettant tout le monde en ville dans
un monde dans lequel l'énergie ne vont
rien
donc c'est normal que vous ayez la
concentration urbaine
et c'est normal que vous ayez des
mégapoles est allé
quand trj commencera valoir quelque
chose tout ce modèle d'aménagement du
territoire sera remis en question et
comme l'aménagement du territoire c'est
pas un truc qui se fait en une semaine
il est évident qu'il faut
considérablement dissiper
ce genre d'évolution si on veut pas
avoir à faire des drames sociaux ce qui
sera que la manière dont ça se
réglera sida
ça a également joué sur notre
alimentation dans cette affaire la mort
là aussi je vais me permettre
d'expliquer que contrairement à ce que
disent d'aucun l'alimentation n'a jamais
coûté aussi peu cher qu'aujourd'hui
pour jamais autant de protéines
animales
vous avez ici les émissions de gaz à
effet de serre d'un certain nombre pour
un certain nombre d'aliments pour la
production d'un kilo d'un certain nombre
d'aliments
et vous voyez que landreau là c'est
pareil le sens de l'histoire 7 et nous
entraîner vers la droite
grâce à l'augmentation du contenu en
hydrocarbures de la nourriture
suite
ces émissions de violette la race est
également liée à l'énergie puisque
c'est les émissions d'épandage des
engrais de synthèse
lesquelles sont faits avec du gaz
naturel donc
sas et les émissions de fabrication des
engrais que vous avez en bleu
les émissions d'épandage des engrais
sont là et en même temps
m jaune ce que vous avez c'est la
méthanisation des ruminants
tous les musées mais si on n'est pas
des déjections
alors vous voyez que au début les gens
à manger des produits végétaux
puissant bien manger des oeufs puissance
et amis à faire la valorisation de
déchets est à déranger les poules
% puis ils se sont mis à manger du
poulet
puis il fut celle des époux l'oeil des
annonces précises pour s'en occuper
pour cent ils sont mis à manger les
produits laitiers puissant bien manger
les bêtes qui donnait les produits
laitiers elle même
le sens de l'histoire
c'est de nous entraîner vers des
aliments qui sont de plus en plus riches
en gaz à effet de serre et qui
nécessitent de plus en plus d'énergie
pour être
dans cinq kilos de crevettes ou un kilo
de thon tropicale
vous avez entre 3 et 3 litres
d'hydrocarbures qui sont actu
dans la pêche ou la production de ses
trois-quarts
dans un kilo de boeuf vous avez parié
d'hydrocarbures qui sont inclus à
travers l'agriculture céréalière
qu'il a fallu faire en amont pour vers
les bestiaux il faut savoir que la
moitié des céréales cultivées dans
ce pays vont nourrir du bétail ans
s'est pas faite pour être mangés
directement
% dentelle c'est la mécanisation et
l'énergie abondante qui a permis de
faire ce genre de choses
et qui a permis cette évolution là
c'est-à-dire de multiplier par cinq
l'accord de la quantité de viande dans
la ration quotidienne
avec un prix qui lui s'est cassé la
gueule
alors vous voyez ici
l'évolution de la part de
l'alimentation dans le budget des
ménages aux etats-unis mais en france
exactement pareil
depuis 1930
et vous voyez que cette part de
l'alimentation et les patients ou d'un
quart du budget à 10%
mais en fait c'est aller encore plus
vite que ça parce que en 1930 les
ménages dans ce qu'ils achètent
hachette 80 % de produits bruts
des patins à des carottes des choses
des oeufs et cetera
or en 2006 ces 20%
les produits bruts dans ce qu'ils
achètent
dans la restauration hors domicile quand
vous allez chez macdo
ce que vous les produits bruts
ces 20% du ticket de caisse
et quand vous allez au supermarché
dès que vous achetez des biscuits des
plats préparés des yaourts des
sociétés cela
c'est-à-dire des produits de
l'industrie agroalimentaire
c'est pareil des produits bruts c'est un
peu près 20 % de ce que vous allez
payer et comme l'agroalimentaire ses 80
% des dépenses d'alimentation des
ménages
en gros aujourd'hui en première
approximation
c'est passer à 20% du total ce qui veut
dire que le prix réel des aliments a
été divisée par dix
ça c'est encore l'énergie abondante et
à bas prix donc attendez-vous à payer
la bouffe plus cher c'est normal
il ya tellement rien d'étonnant
là-dedans pour des raisons physiques
voilà ce que je suis en train de vous
expliquer puis une demi-heure c'est que
on a
toutes bâties tout notre équilibre
socio-économique actuel nation un truc
d'une simplicité biblique
trouver des trucs qui brûle sous terre
les faire brûler
grâce à ça avoir les moteurs et la
chimie
élévateurs et la chimie nous ont
amené la totalité de ce qui vous
entoure tout autour de vous les moteurs
et chimie
il sera évidemment ça a également
amené le système socio-économique
dans lequel nous vivons
% et l'urbanisme la structure des
métiers et la retraite à 60 ans en
faveur d un peu en dessous maintenant
que ça va remonter ça c'est évident
voilà les études longues qui vont se
raccourcir
% et le divorce qui va diminuer la
présidence a diminué
or parce que plante les gens divorcent
les axes conjoint obama a par
conservation d'énergie de 60 %
instantanément il faut construire deux
fois plus de logements
il faut les chauffer
il faut multiplier par deux tous les
objets de la vie courante le lilas
belloir la baule vouloir électrique et
cetera
donc il faut consommer à regarder mon
divorce dans les pays qui consomme pas
d'énergie
dans ces pays-là plein divorce nous
payons divorce pas
donc dans un monde contraint en énergie
vous allez avoir les contraintes sur le
pouvoir d'achat et sava contrat le
divorce
donc la totalité du mais on ne dans
laquelle nous vivons
état civil
sur un truc qui est tout bête
et qui s'appelle les combustibles
fossiles
alors tout ça c'est parfait dans un
monde infini dans un monde fini ça
posait question
la première c'est combien de temps et
ce que je peut creuser
à vitesse accélérée sous le sol pour
faire sortir en quantité croissante ces
fichus combustibles fossiles
et une deuxième question qui et combien
de temps à ce que je peux mettre le
sous-produit de cette combustion dans
l'atmosphère
avant que la modification des échanges
énergétiques entre la surface et
l'espace que ça réduit
de me perturbe le climat
de manière telle que je trouve à
l'expérience extrêmement saumâtre
alors je vais traiter est beaucoup plus
la première que la deuxième question
parce que vu l'endroit où je suis je
considère que la deuxième question on
savait déjà pas mal et si ces faux
tant pis pour vous il faut faire un
choix
je vais reprendre 1% et ce que je vous
disais tout à l'heure sur l'énergie et
voilà comment a évolué la quantité
d'énergie totale consommée par
l'humanité or bois depuis un siècle et
demi donc ses consommations par personne
foin de personnes tout à l'heure vous
avez justement ces consommation par
personne
alors vous voyez encore une fois les
augmentations qui ont été tellement
tellement vite en ce qui concerne la
quantité d'énergie consommée entre la
génération des parents la génération
des enfants est quasiment un facteur 10
sur la quantité d'énergie qui a été
consommée par les hommes c'est
absolument monstrueux
et vous voyez que 80% de cette énergie
et faites 2 stark
à la faille tirer de stock alors cette
énergie-là est ce qu'on appelle
énergie primaire c'est celle qu'on
trouve dans la nature
et pour cela je suis tout petit peu de
rock la thur
dans la nature vous de trouver cossart
vous trouvez du charbon coup trouver du
pétrole outre et du gaz vous trouvez
des noyaux qui veulent bien se casser en
deux et vous trouvez ce qu'on appelle
les énergies renouvelables
voilà donc la combustion du bois % et
les élus lhopiteau honda % et cetera le
vent qui souffle
vous mettez à si peu de vent qui
souffle dans votre voiture et vous
utilisez assez peu de charbon brut pour
faire tourner une question électrique
vous ce que vous allez utiliser c'est ce
qu'on appelle d énergie finale
c'est à dire
des transformations de c conduit stib
là
pour avoir des trucs qui rentre dans les
machines dont nous nous servons
alors les machines dont nous nous
servons ceux des chaudières des
voitures
décati a été équipé de ses pairs
donc là on va dans votre reer pour ceux
qui en utilisent encore du charbon sous
une forme qui il a parlé poids à l'afp
on va trouver carburant raffiné et
philologue
puis le supercarburant et cetera diesel
on va trouver du gaz purifier parce que
là quand de sa soeur l'étape de dents
dont vous avez pas envie dans les
réseaux de transport par exemple le gaz
de la mer du nord et peut compter
jusqu'à 10 % de ses eaux 2 quand il
sort il vous avez pas envie de mettre le
seconde dans les tuyaux
comme vous allez trouver d'électricité
qui n'existe pas dans la nature sauf à
capter les orages
alors je vous signale que ya une blague
je suis désolé pour nos amis
américains mais il ya une blague que je
veux que on entend souvent
qui a que quand vous faites un sondage
aux etats-unis et vous demandez aux gens
d'où vient l'idée de garder tous ses
efforts à faire en france impôts
dounia l'électricité la moitié des
gens vous disent du mur
ben oui le feu
avant lui à la hussarde
avant lui réussir
à la retraite cette énergie finale
vous ne l'utilisez pas juste pour le
plaisir de voir aller d'essence brûlé
vous allez en tirer
ce qu'on appelle de l'énergie utile
c'est à dire du mouvement quand vous
mettez à les descendants une voiture
qui vous intéressent vraiment ce
mouvement
quand vous mettez un litre d'essence
d'employés de fioul dans une chaudière
qui vous intéressent vraiment c
l'élévation de température dans une
pièce
donc en gros ce qui va vous intéresser
c'est ce qu'on appelle d'énergie utile
et à chaque fois que vous franchissez
une étape
de primaire à finalité de finale a
utilement à les perdre en route et une
partie de l'énergie
l'essentiel de l'énergie perdue de
primaire afida à l'appel elle est
composée en sarthe
parce que monsieur carnot a dit que
quand vous commencez par faire de la
chaleur pour faire du mouvement
vous allez en perdant un sacré paquet
au passage
or 85 % d'électricité mondiale est
faite en commençant par faire bouillir
de l'eau
qu'il s'agisse des centrales à charbon
ag à 'ses à fuel nucléaire tout cela
ces faire bouillir de l'eau
d'une manière différente mais sait
faire bouillir de l'eau
et donc à l'arrivée vous allez perdre
n'importe quoi
en trois heures
45' dans les excellents cas de figure
que 80% dans les mauvais
de la chaleur initial
et pour le nucléaire n'a pas l'apanage
des mauvais rendements les centrales à
charbon dans le monde - roman qui a
beaucoup à celui des centrales
nucléaires donc c'est pas c'est pas
juste c'est l'ump qui ne sait pas trop
quand vous allez passer de finale à
l'itinéraire
vous avez aussi avoir des pertes alors
là il peut être considérable pour
cent si je reprends vous créez votre
organisme qui même très bien nourrie
le va'a rapidement rarement pardon le
dépasser les 100 kilos
pas si je considère que vous jouerez
dans une voiture d'une polémique pour
avancer
l'énergie vraiment utile c'est celle
qui dépassent votre corps
or l'énergie finale que vous allez
utiliser c'est un peu plus que ça
donc écoles en passant de l'énergie
finale à utile c'est-à-dire de service
que ça rend